[Music]
what up guys welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever we
want and today we have a
ask an expert segment with ron a pro
fighter
hello okay ron i gotta know this
so we're all tubers we know tubers who
suck ass
we know troopers who are cool as a
fighter
you must know some popular fighters who
are [ __ ] [ __ ]
or either [ __ ] people or [ __ ] technique
and you're just like how the [ __ ] did
they do this and all that kind of [ __ ]
without naming names necessarily but you
can
obviously if you want if you want to
torpedo your career yeah you can
you have the freedom too but there yeah
there
there are some fighters there that are
not so nice it happens you know it's
just
the nature of people and then there's
some fighters out there it's like
they're in there and i'm not but that's
my but it's because my own personal
choices
uh why i'm not there and they are no
it's not some [ __ ] dude
i blame everything on myself that's
right don't you
like because you have some of your
teammates in the ufc does it feel weird
that you're like
oh man i want to be there too oh
definitely um i definitely want to be
there
all the time i'm like fudge man you
never think about like maybe like
spiking their drink
no no and they're like hey i'm free
like a pageant girl they're there
because they
they did what they were supposed to um
when they got there you know um the
reason why i
i haven't i'm not in the ufc yet is
because i've dispersed my attention too
many ways
you know whereas my teammates that are
in the ufc they focused on nothing but
getting there you know
yeah but with me all my endeavors that
i've done across you know and then um
acquiring positions and whatnot um it
took focus away from the main goal which
is
give everything up you know and get into
the ufc
why do you always take so much
responsibility just blame somebody else
for something it's way more fun
it's so much more fun it told me i'm
sorry like i have friends who went on
snl and i'm like it's
this is [ __ ]
yeah i mean man we have such boring
friends because they're so
sensible and they're like god they're
like inspirational
they don't have the victim mentality
it's like i did it to myself
it's true why can't we have friends that
are a little bit more shittier like
that's what i'm saying
crappy fans i also like how ask the
expert is we're just going to talk to
bart's friends
for now we're the first couple what um
what are some of the biggest
misconceptions of fighting of mma you
think
uh mismatch being a pro fighter like
what are some things that you think oh
man the public definitely got this part
of it wrong
um we're a bunch of meatheads that's
probably the biggest one we're a bunch
of meat heads
and uh we're very very violent so it's
almost like the
the the stigma that when you see a pit
bull you know you're like well stay here
from the pit bull you know we see
somebody that says they're a cage
fighter an mma fighter they're like whoa
man don't beat me up
you know it's kind of cool though i
think i think that's pretty sick
for me it's almost kind of embarrassing
um i'm actually kind of embarrassed to
say it
it's a weird thing to say and i was like
hey you know so what do you do i'm a
cage fighter that's so sick to say are
you [ __ ] kidding me that's
it sounds it sounds so made up and like
you know and that
that that's true i'm a cage fighter and
then take your drink and drink it
you know what [ __ ] in retrospect i
should have i should have used it i'm a
catchphrase
now that's right he doesn't want to be
the meme
sir you can't have that beer outside
just because it's because i said so
yeah you mentioned sir what oh
i you know i should have told you before
i hit you you can't have the beer
outside
you hit first and then all the order was
off strike first
do you ever visualize how you would take
somebody down like is that part of your
guys's thing
is is just and you're in the moment like
in the ring do you visualize it
only when you're repeating and competing
like real you'll you strategize on what
generally going to do and you actually
memorize
sequences that you may do there's a few
different styles of training but one
style is to memorize sequences so you'll
do a sequence of movements
and you'll practice that over and over
and it becomes involuntary um
based on the fact that it may be
effective against your opponent and then
come fight time you run through that
sequence because it's
it's second nature what's the most
popular thing that you see maybe in the
ufc
in the ufc like or technique-wise that
you're like oh
i wish they didn't do that but that we
don't even see it all um
one thing i see a lot is uh not checking
leg kicks so somebody coming from a muay
thai background a lot of mma fighters
well sitting at mma is you're not
getting somebody that's a master in
every single discipline
they're getting something that's really
really good in a bunch of disciplines
and maybe a master of one
maybe two you know so you'll see just
like you see
you'll see an mma fighter fight a boxer
and most of the time they'll never win
you know uh because they have so much
more skill and straight
punching than an mma fighter because mma
fighter doesn't just punch
the elbow they need they like mayweather
you know like uh
a lot of people say that conor mcgregor
actually did really really good
but for me looking at it i felt that
mayweather was toying with him the whole
time
and mcgregor happened to just just land
a few heavy shots
you know by accident by just because
that's the striking that's a game of
striking it's all probabilities you know
and then what happened towards the end
mayweather picked it up like if you look
closely at that fight you'll see a major
difference from the first
few rounds to the last few rounds and
all of a sudden mayweather
all of a sudden it got faster and
sharper and quicker you know because he
was toying with him like he did it for
the money he put on the show
yeah you know um he did it for our money
we watched it together it was pretty
sick
yeah it was a good show to watch yeah
you know can you imagine if mayweather
just like finished him in the first
round
they'd be like oh shoot i'm not watching
this again yeah
you know but he he he gave us a sense
that oh my gosh mcgregor might have a
chance of
finishing mayweather telling a story in
there yeah he he was he was storytelling
yeah like like
the tyson fight like what did you think
about that well because obviously they
couldn't knock each other out and all
that and everyone was
waiting for some like tyson unleashing i
wanted it so bad yeah that's gonna be
the second coming of mike tyson
and i wasn't sure if they were really
going at it or they were just sparring
honestly uh i was i was eating dinner
with my family
and uh the fight was going on they asked
me are you gonna watch the fight i was
like
no i went back to eating
because i knew i knew exactly what was
going on um it was gonna be a freaking
snore fest because one they weren't
allowed to kill each other
yeah so you knew the rules before i
didn't know about those rules
i didn't either i didn't know it was
going to be a snore fest until i watched
it now we were hyped as [ __ ] yeah
dude roy jones jr tyson on paper he met
like because we think of tyson
you think of any fighter you think of
them in their prime you don't think that
them at their worst you know so when i
think tyson i'm like looking back at all
his highlight reels i look at roy jones
jr i look at him doing all that crazy
crap and knocking pools out yeah you
know but we don't think about the
reality is that they're freaking
two old dudes that probably just started
training heavily like four weeks ago he
still look moves good though
oh dude he moves amazing yeah it's crazy
no matter how old you are if you're a
master of something like you still have
freaking great great skill he also lost
the hundred pounds
holy crap a hundred pounds he did that's
good that's so sweet
yeah he looked good yeah
you know but but i knew it was gonna
happen they they they released the rules
like i think a week or two before the
fight and as soon as i saw that i was
like
uh you know you knew what it was going
to happen yeah i was like oh this is
literally i think we were all hoping for
tyson to
be a little like with this holy field
match and just say [ __ ] it
yeah and then like the warrior comes out
because he kept talking about the
warriors the goddess
war is live inside me again all that
[ __ ] dude i thought it was gonna snap
and then like you know we were gonna see
that unleashed but it didn't
yep and it was obviously a one-off
because if they were trying to build a
sequel
they would they would have put more
action into it yeah but i mean nobody is
going to pay for a rematch i just think
the god of war is a [ __ ] now probably
is what happened
he got possessed by the god of war and
god of war is kind of [ __ ] now
to me that wasn't even an edge fest it
was like didn't even get hard
no yeah what do you think about
mayweather and logan paul you think
that's going to be like another
snorefest
no i think that's going to be
interesting uh when that happens why
because of the size difference
major size difference and i don't it's
it's tough because i don't think it's
good for boxing um not because a
youtuber is fighting but because
if he stops mayweather or hurts him like
it's gonna completely like diminish
because nobody thinks about the size
difference or the strength difference
if he somehow wins a youtuber beat
one of the greatest boxers of all time
he'll be so great i would love that so
it would diminish like it would like
really
hurt boxing yeah it would ruin the
legitimacy of boxing yeah because then
youtubers would take over every single
sport after that and i can laugh my ass
off
can you imagine like yeah dude uh
youtubers in ufc in golf in basketball
in hockey
in freaking baseball and all you took
was of all it took was a following
and barely any training yeah
is there any hope in hell though that he
could win i mean honestly i think there
is
because of the size difference because
of the size so logan's so much bigger
than mayweather because the punching is
significantly bigger than mayweather you
know mayweather just like five
six or five he's my size oh [ __ ]
mayweather's my size logan paul is kind
of a big dude
he's like six something right yeah he's
a big guy you know and so
physics have to come and play at some
point you know and so
i don't think mayweather hits harder in
the local poll just because of sheer
size difference you know but what about
mayweather's skill like he's like he's
got to be able to see it coming
oh of course all the way i would say i
would say nine times nine point nine
times out of ten
mayweather's gonna wreck him just based
on technique he's gonna gas him out
whatever
but it's not like logan paul is
completely untrained it's not like he's
very challenging
yeah like his work at that actually
shows he's putting in the time he just
doesn't have the experience
but a punch is a punch and nothing is
guaranteed you know so as good as
mayweather is there's still a chance
that
logan paul may land a punch well you're
telling me to put money on this you're
literally telling me to put money on
this fight
i think it's a good bet it's a good bet
because i'm a huge underdog right logan
paul
i would assume so i would assume he's a
major underdog i'm gonna go hard on this
i think
you know i would i would go hard enough
where if you lose it it won't hurt you
i don't play like that i don't know i
don't play like that i'm gonna play that
game
maybe logan might not win but you can
bet that he's gonna get a shot
he might land a poncho if he knocks out
mayweather and then he wins
you're right boxing is destroyed forever
destroyed and i honestly i think that's
more feasible than
than uh than his brother fighting like
dylan dennis
oh no that one i was like uh i think i
just love chaos
though that one's gonna be chaotic like
what's wrong with the jake paul fighting
dylan dance you think
jake paul win or dylan dance would win
uh i don't know
really dylan that sucks that bad it's
because i know he's a jiu jitsu expert
right he's amazing at jiu jitsu
but his hands are that bad because jake
paul looked like he just don't have i
mean
he just started boxing like a year or
two ago right it's it's tough man
because fighting is fighting you know
um a punch is a punch like it's there
dylan dennis doesn't exactly have the
tightest of defenses
so it only takes one overhand one lucky
overhand
um to really hurt somebody if you're if
you're telling logan paul
right now you're in his corner and
you're like here's how to take
mayweather down what would you tell him
i would tell him hold him pick him up
put him into the corner because he's big
enough to
um and then just start wailing f
technique don't be clean don't
just crowd him and then just corner him
yeah just completely flustered him
um if mayweather moves he has no chance
whatsoever
but luckily there's a ring and there are
corners to the ring so if
if logan paul can so if it was an
octagon or a circle mayweather would
have way better chance of circling it
out but because it's a ring yeah just
cornering him yeah if he can manage to
corner mayweather and just throw
haymakers
that's his only chance of winning um if
if mayweather can keep his distance he
has no chance but if you can get him
there
and it's as easy as literally just
pushing him i mean he's big enough or if
he pushes him hard once he may fly to
the ring
and he's got that reach too i mean he's
a big figure he's a big freak you could
actually pushing the boxing's okay yeah
you can push it
and just throw this one yeah it's nice
but you can't can you keep a stiff arm
is that part of the rules
you can you can stiff them you just
can't hold on to them you can push off
them right
you can shove your hand in his face and
as you put your hand off you can we
worked on that posting
posting right in their face or shoulder
to line up your shot you can do that you
just can't
hold on to them i just knew that like
different sports have different like
rules and stuff
yeah yeah so boxing has its own rules
kickboxing has its own rules muay thai
has its own rules
um sanshu all those do you think they're
gonna have headgear that i don't know
it is supposed to be a profile if it's
pro then there's no headgear if you were
advising
um jake paul now what would you tell him
i would
i would say trade as hard as you can get
every coach i mean because he's putting
money into it he's not just jumping in
he's getting like
i think he's getting like uh like
professional training
at his house yeah like he's actually
putting multiple two actually they both
bought like straight up
like a legit ring they just put in their
house they're training full-time
and it's like i gotta say they are
gifted and they have good work ethic i
mean they they are where they are
because of their workout
you know not by luck you know and so
they're taking that same work i think
i'm playing the boxing
the only difference is they're cramming
like maybe six months to a year of
training
um and maybe putting two or three years
of training in six to 12 months that's
why you did private so you can
accelerate
your learning you know if you did it on
your own you wouldn't be as good as you
are now i still wouldn't challenge
anybody
no yeah they're very different they're
very daring you know um i wouldn't
dream of fighting a professional athlete
with only like a year or less of
experience do you think logan would kick
bart's ass
because i do i think he would be
disastrous i think maybe because one
he's way bigger
um and two he's probably putting in more
time so can you just say out loud for me
like
because everyone wants to see that fight
yeah that means
if you if you were to go full time
because it's like we we train maybe like
what twice a week you know yeah i
wouldn't at the most at the most
you know if you're training you're doing
like seven days a week yeah if you're
training like seven days a week
you can have you might have a chance oh
but for now you think you would die yeah
i would die you would die oh [ __ ] your
cardio is shot like
this you haven't trained since covid you
know and jake paul is freaking like
training like right now probably
he's probably like running like there's
footage of him training
both of the guys training right now yeah
but i don't know jake paul is as big as
logan paul
no i think he's much your own coach
think both paul's a tick kick your ass i
know what does that say i mean it's
devastating
what's up you know what the best thing
about this is what we just did to him
he's going to be up at three in the
morning now [ __ ] no i'm not doing
push-ups he's like
no no my coach threw in the towel before
i
went throwing a wet nap so i guess what
i'm getting from all of this is like
at the end of the day size does matter
big time in fighting that's why they
have weight classes to a degree yeah if
size didn't matter there'd be no weight
classes yeah you know but
there's such a he's got to have maybe
like 50 60 pounds of mayweather
psy's and athleticism though so logan's
big but he also knows how to move yeah
he's an athlete he's actually just big
he doesn't know how to move i think it'd
be way less
athletic if he was like uh if he was
who's who's not very clumsy yeah who's
kind of clumsy just like a
um regular person regular that's a
profiler
jason chen
you know he moves way better now but
when he first started coming like he was
just so clumsy yes if it was
if it was pre-training jason chen yes
you know his only chance of winning
would be to sing his way out of the
fight
you know he captivates people with his
music and we're like because even if he
was like six something too much
he was like 200 pounds over six feet
tall he just
just the way he moved he was gonna tell
you what he's gonna do before he even
did yeah just absolutely no chance so if
if 200 pound um over five foot jason
chen
um would get into a fight right now and
trained uh to fight me there no chance
no chance if you were in bart's corner
goddammit
versus logan paul i assume you'd be in
this corner but maybe the guy who
knocked you out i think he's gonna be in
the other guy's corner
logan's carter he's gonna quit the day
of the fight how does bart beat logan
bart would beat logan on movement um he
would have to keep circ he's gonna play
the same strategy as mayor was gonna
play
um tight defense circle island jumping
in and out and picking the shots
um logan paul is gonna fire heavy shots
heavy single shots um unless somehow he
improves dramatically and from now until
the supposed fight but he's gonna fire
single shots he's gonna make a miss come
in and out in and out pop up in and out
and just break him down um we're not
gonna try to finish him we're just gonna
try to
break him down and hopefully his cardio
is subject
if we're training he's running a
marathon like he's going to be running
um and he would just pick his shots and
break them down
that's awesome dude this is i want to
just [ __ ] ask you
how to beat people because you're really
this is very fascinating it's like it's
a science right it like cracks
on top of the the just the technical
how-to's right
what i'm more thinking about is like
how do you stay level-headed with all
the adrenaline because i was thinking
earlier
like um you said after like what three
fights
professional fights you no longer get
intimidated by
humans that are aggressive and angry
they might be yelling at you
at the bar or whatever but then you just
don't feel that
feel fear that you used to right but
that must apply in the ring too right
where it's like
you're no long you're just kind of it's
a sport now where you're just kind of
like
trying to figure out the the area to go
to in your head
instead of like being like oh [ __ ] i
gotta get myself hyped up and then like
kill this fool
yeah now it's more like uh confidence
grows over time you know with the
experience and training confidence
growth so i'm at this point and i was
like
already put on the work now it's the fun
part now i just gotta execute it's over
you know let's do this um so just tunnel
vision
um of course you'll get butterflies just
like performing anything you know
um there's some sort of essence of fear
nobody's fearless
but definitely i have much less fear now
than i did in the beginning so it's a
the fear changes uh fear of
disappointment fear of uh letting people
down
um fear of yeah yeah that's that's my
biggest fear so the first fear is like
i hope i i hit them or like i hope i
don't get hit hard right and then the
second
the then it grows into like oh
other kind of fears no so yeah even uh
it's really just your disappointment
because so many people put so much time
and effort into you
and then if you don't if you don't
deliver of course they still love you
and carry you and support you
and don't change coaches to the winning
team
i think you should consider it thanks
because i think the
most people in the beginning is like
they'll be like i don't want to get hurt
that's the basic fear i think that you
first start off because you don't want
to get hit
and then or like um or or or like
i hope i could land this punch fear fear
is a good motivator you know once i
i finally got my first concussion which
was like last year i think um
it finally realizes like hey i don't
want to get hit anymore i'm like
it took six hours i was i literally
wasted six months of my life
feeling not myself so your defense got
better yeah
yeah oh i find different now so i don't
fight like this i'm freaking here now
like it took a concussion for me to
realize like hey i don't want to feel
like that ever again so the fear of
getting a concussion
um ever again is completely ingrained
into like my being so like that anxiety
control
um when you're in these tough situations
what do you do
tell yourself or like what what works
out in your mind
where you stay calm or try to stay calm
when you're like
in a tense situation singular focus
um if you're thinking about too much
it's already over you know if you're in
the midst of it you're like dang i do
what i do what i need to adjust when i
like crap like i'm losing whatever it's
already over what about
if your mind goes um i want to kill this
person but that's not a good idea
like like when like i'm confronted right
like
or like i feel danger like i think um
while i'm still sensible my mind goes
like what can i do to murder this guy as
fast as possible and then the other part
is like
that's illegal you're gonna go to jail
don't do that that's
one once you get to once you put it in
your head that you're going to kill
somebody
and you're capable of doing it um with
the work ethic that you put in as a
fighter you're going to kill them
you know the same thank god i'm
untrained
i'm gonna keep you on train yeah it's
the same intelligence i go into a fight
you know i'm not
i'm not thinking i'm gonna kill this
guy's like no i'm gonna destroy this guy
i'm gonna implement my strategy i'm
going to beat him
um in the ways that i've trained to do
it you know if my mentality was i need
to end his life
then i would fight differently you know
to end his life so in a self-defense
situation
it's never i need to freaking make this
i need to put this guy in the hospital i
just need to subdue him
literally that's my most aggressive
thought i need to make it so he can't
hit me
oh like kind of like how judo guys would
just drop them
instead of like choking them out or
whatever yeah just
just just make it so that they can't
move i see you know um
and that's that's as far as i go i i
have no thought of ever trying to end
somebody's life because i know i can't
so because you're you're so trained in
all this stuff when you watch mayweather
fight because i think mayweather is
probably the most boring champion we've
had
i think a lot of people think that you
you think that too he's very boring okay
cool
but he's also very technical yeah it's
like uh when i watch mayweather
i'm going to school i'm learning you
know i'm not having fun i'm learning
um it's like listening to jazz right
it's not the funnest song but it's
probably like the most technical
music you're ever here yes if i knew
anything about music
but when you're okay so this is great so
how would you take on mayweather
how would i take on mayweather that's
gonna be tough because he's
hits harder than me he's faster than me
and he's got way more experience than me
and so my game is i would have to just
walk forward
um same game is uh as uh fighting
against uh
the same strategy as logan paul i'll try
to push him in the corner and try to
muscle my way
uh tight defense is possible i need to
get in the corner where he's most
vulnerable and just unload but with
tight defense so instead of just winging
shots
i'll just throw quick heavy tight tight
bot tight and in hopes that something
gets through but that's also like
boxing versus boxing right yeah boxing
and then i would have to
change my stance in my style too as well
um if it was just boxing if it was mma
shoot that change because then he's in
new york that changes
yeah i will beat mayweather an mma fight
um that i know for sure
um and so it's what fight would i beat
logan paul
holding your breath underwater i think
you're good at tic-tac-toe man like ooh
dude you trigger wreck them laser tag
you're pretty good
mafia what about uh shitty agents
yeah yeah there you go he doesn't even
know what that game is see
you can win on his radar you better
who's your favorite fighter real quick
before we go anderson silva
oh nice oh yeah he's creative how come
um he's creative he's unorthodox he's
southpaw or most of the time and i'm
southpaw too as well
um and he he embodies that martial arts
spirit
that i love i love the martial arts he
has a good balance of being honorable
but still very entertaining mm-hmm yeah
he's for me he's the
he's the fighter that if there was one i
would want to be like who's the goat
boxer of all time the goat
boxer of all time i like pacquiao um
i don't think he's the best boxer all
the time uh but he's my favorite boxer
pacquiao he's my guest
he's yeah his style is pretty
entertaining he's very fun to watch
his his prime [ __ ] though like wow yeah
he's [ __ ] i think he can fight mike
mcgregor i think he's really they're
having they're talking about
that yeah [ __ ] when when isn't mcgregor
fighting he's literally funny tonight
yeah my god so he'll fight again next
week yeah millions of dollars
you